the smoke there's dust there's sand
there's heat there's blood there's guts
and then you've got an ear piece in with
people screaming you and I knew
I knew that if I
um if I closed my eyes I'd be dead and I
remember unlocking my phone and WhatsApp
was on and I kind of closed what's up
and clicked on the camera
and the second I clicked the film
I saw what I guess the whole world saw
[Music]
foreign
can you tell us about the night who you
were going to the concert with and who
you were going to see so I was going
with my daughter Eve she was 14 at the
time
and the tickets I'd bought as a a
surprise at Christmas you know I'll say
we spent kind of the daddy and daughter
time was
um kind of going to concerts and you
know just loved music and singing and so
yes it was just really that the night
was just a celebration of that really
so we were
we were in one of the very first boxes
up in the it's kind of like Midway up uh
in the arena so if if you were if I was
Ariana Grande singing on the stage we
were kind of like the first box here
um when she came out it was obviously a
morsely girls but like literally I had
to cover me ears it was that like
honestly it was like deafening uh and
yeah she put on a good show
it was a really good concert what
happened after the concert finished
where did you guys go
you know when we um
we when we when we go out of the
um the Box obviously we we we do a right
into the city room
at 10 30 we'll make our way through and
then that's obviously when someone abair
did detonated his his suicide burst
it was Operation pound for claw
and it was Operation named Herrick 10.
it was in 2009 I've been out there
pretty much for my six month tour
we was in a fob called fob leaning
forward operating base
was in the front line there
um
and basically
I had to go down the same road which was
called Pharmacy Road
and this is where we lost five Lads and
several wounded and other people had
been injured and killed on the same road
so it was Notorious
and
my job would be the Valen man v a double
o n and that's to find the IEDs I was
first man out last man back in
and on this day
my platoon Commander
Mr Hillard he um
I remember him kicking my bunk and
saying Jakey I want you on this Patrol I
didn't need to be on this Patrol but I
was asked to go on it
and
it was another regiment coming in
and they were leading the patrol
and I was good at my job as a valid man
Leading Men bringing them back in safe
but I hadn't failed
but the one day that I wasn't patrolling
and leading them in all hell broke loose
what were you doing the day of the
exclusion the day of the explosion
August 4th so Joe
um one of my best friends he decided
that he wanted to have Burgers from from
this one little place in in downtown
Beirut in Madame is this very vibrant
little area where you know it's full of
pubs and bars and restaurants and shops
and clubs and all sorts of things right
about when we finished
um at this point it was around six
6 p.m Beirut time
um
we heard a loud explosion
and we saw the
the uh the glass screen of the store
facing the burger shop kind of shake and
start the crack
so I felt like the building was gonna
collapse on us
so we run out of the store and I pulled
Joe and Karim and we get out and
I look to the left
and uh it's like kind of like down the
street
and that's where the port is so at the
end of the street you kind of get to an
intersection where you can see the port
and uh I'm kind of standing at the
intersection of the street where there's
actually nothing between me and the port
from that point to Ground Zero that
warehouse of basically where where
things started
um I was 650 meters away and I'm looking
at this huge cloud of smoke that's just
going up and there were Sparks in it and
and it looked like things were happening
and can you remember the moment that
that happened when the bomb detonated
yeah yeah we're we're only six meters
away I've only just found out initially
we were told we were 10 meters away
but I found out
um about four or five weeks ago there
were actually only six meters away
there was a small small Arms contact I
was injured in the first explosion the
second explosion
then came by my platoon sergeant my
sniper Sergeant Paul mcaleese there was
a bit of misunderstanding between me and
mcaleese and he um he tripped the
secondary device which unfortunately
killed him and then injured me
I mean and then in that moment you're
kind of paralyzed at the thought of
going on
um
I mean I remember thinking is this war
like is was it an attack what's going on
like what are we gonna do where do we go
and I remember unlocking my phone on
WhatsApp was on and I kind of closed
what's up and clicked on the camera
and the second I clicked the film
I saw what I guess the whole world saw
I just remember I just felt winded
and I think I I obviously I I didn't
know it were a bomb
I initially I thought I'd been shot or
stabbed
and and I couldn't get my breath
um so I panicked uh because I was like
like [ __ ] like what's going on like I
couldn't breathe
um
and then I think I must have lost
Consciousness then because the next
thing I know I'm kind of lying on the
floor
and and basically like gargling on on
blood and obviously I can I can say I'm
losing a lot of blood
um and then obviously I see Eve's not in
a good way
um and then that's kind of when our
probably know just from
kind of what's going on in the room that
it's obviously a bomb you know I knew I
wasn't in a good way and I knew I was
dying I knew I was losing a lot of blood
um and I just remember kind of saying to
myself you know you you're not gonna
make it you know you you've got one job
to do now and that's to you know make
sure Eve gets out and I knew
I knew that if I um if I closed my eyes
I'd be dead
like to see some
to your daughter
nice the worst worst thing on earth
um
because again I give myself a hard time
about it because
you know like most dads you know I
always said to Eve like you never worry
when you were me because I'll protect
you and keep you safe and nothing will
ever happen so I kind of feel like I've
let her down and kind of failed as a dad
and
um yeah not me we're obviously shouting
out for help and
you know they
people were telling us that paramedics
were on the way and help was on the way
but it just felt like forever
um
and you know a lot of people have said
and that my family have said like they
were always worried and upset for me
because they thought I were in loads of
pain and
scared and stuff but I wasn't I was like
really calm and
I wasn't in any pain
actually I was like really like I say I
was just literally just concentrating on
I even
just kind of
my breathing and just you know because I
knew like if I panicked I'd probably
lose more blood and so just to be
thinking of things like that when you're
dying it's just crazy really but kind of
an acceptance that I probably wasn't
going to make it and I said to Chris the
security guard that was was with me I
tell my wife I love her
I suppose one second
foreign
[Music]
yeah it doesn't mean that it will get
easier though
what did that impact feel like when I
hit you
it's impossible to describe there's
nothing like it I mean when you want to
describe something you try to find the
closest thing to it there was nothing
like that feeling
um
I remember the first thing I felt was
dust filling the back of my eyes because
the first thing that gets to you is that
pressure pressure cloud
and then I just flew
I flew and I remember everything
um
kind of like white and smoke and and
debris of all sorts of flying everywhere
and following that
the moment of liftoff came the sound
because sound travels slower
and that was the most horrific sound
that I had ever heard
it sounded as though something had like
murdered the Earth and the Earth was
roaring back of from Agony and pain
and then lights up
what did it feel like at the moment
it's going to take more than a plaster
to fix this one
it just it just it just you just knew
it's like you can you just know I can't
explain it it's
when mcaleese took that that that that
move I just knew what was coming it's
milliseconds and your brain is
registering it but it's not the body
can't do nothing about it it's just you
just have to accept it
there's smoke there's dust there's sand
there's heat there's blood there's guts
and then you've got an ear piece in with
people screaming you
so what happened after the injury
talking to the lads and the ladies on
the ground
they tell me that
I was really pissed off and apparently I
Casey myself backwards behind the
machine guns and I was
stripped down to my boots because that's
what the explosion did to me it flipped
me back but apparently I stood up and I
wasn't too pleased that's what they tell
me and then uh apparently I collapsed
lack of blood
and because the end of the day shrapnel
ripped through my right thigh rip
through my um upper right arm
shrapnel through the nose through the
right eye into the brain
what is it they say two millimeters from
my throat
so I'm lucky to be here really
at some point I was
knocked up so whether it was for a
minute or two I really don't know and I
mean I was blown further back
um I got up and inside a restaurant
which was I think a few
10 15 meters behind me I had Cuts all
over my body from glass I found that in
my
left foot there was a huge Shard of
glass that kind of gone through the
bottom
um
and usually these things
like you shouldn't remove them because
they kind of become the plug to your
body so you don't you know bleed out but
my first reaction was like I can't even
walk it's bigger than my entire leg so I
just pull it out and I
walked out
just walking through that street was
a horror movie I mean anything that
you could possibly imagine in terms of
um injuries people
like hanging from balconies like just
sitting in like blood everywhere
children like limbs missing arms legs I
didn't even I'd even check to see if
anything was was wrong I mean I could
move my arms and my legs so I thought
I was lucky
I don't think people
um
when other people understand like they
you know for your mind to go through
that and your body to go through that
you know too
gonna make peace with yourself
and almost like um
like an acceptance to the situation
and like to like to say like so people
you don't know like to tell your wife
you love her you don't think you're
gonna like see anybody again
and it's a tough thing like it that like
to accept that it's um
it's a tough thing to go through and
that's why I'm like dead happy now to be
alive because like for an hour
all right so I have to go through that
and just like fight and be alone and
scared and
you know it was awful
and what injuries did you sustain so uh
so for 22 shrapnel wounds from head to
toe
was one that hit me in the center of the
back
um completely severed my spinal cord at
T10 level which in layman's terms means
I'm paralyzed from the belly button down
I mean I had one that had gone through
my arm
um smash my uncle my tibia my fibio
but they
the
second
hit me on the side of the neck seven two
arteries
and then yeah swallowed it ended up in
my stomach
a stroke of luck that
well yeah there's no no explanation like
I said they're just it's just they've
said it is it's a miracle where just how
close we were you know because
people died everyone around us died
pretty much instantly
um yeah so yeah there's just no nobody
can explain it
from coma to talking
there was no dramas with that because I
was in a hospital and a military
hospital where everyone had lost arms
and legs and there was something wrong
with someone and
your mind with all the
drugs
sleeping the routine
you didn't really get a chance to think
about it but it's only when you went
home
not that I had a home to go to but
when he was left alone should I say and
you wasn't in the hospital environment
with routine medication
the realization of strikes
so the first year I actually had a bit
of sight that I could walk around on my
own
and the hospital did an operation and it
failed
so I spent a whole year with Hope and
Faith
to then do an operation and then being
told it was a
it was a failure and
yeah
I'm not an emotional man but you know
when you have so much faith and hope
that you're going to be able to see at
least
and then you land in that hospital bed
and you can't use your right arm you can
barely walk
and you bring the lamp to your face and
you're flicking the light on and off
just for that glimmer of hope that
little bit there was nothing
what were the hardest things for you to
learn over again
accepting who I am and what I am
um and I'm never going to be what I
wanted to be I have to be this whole
different person now so
I'll give you an example I've got a 10
year old son I've never seen him
he's the only reason I'm living
he's the only reason for existence
because as you can probably imagine
it's quite hard sometimes when I'm fine
I'm wearing PTSD
but you know I have to just keep
thinking that
that's a little man that needs me and I
will keep fighting
and that and that's that's the state
he's just he's my hero
and how's your daughter Eve today she's
doing all right you know
um the first time I went over to see her
uh one of the things I do remember is is
one of the consultants in Manchester
saying
you know she's
you know there's probably not going to
be much there you know I should probably
won't see she probably won't hear
she probably won't speak she won't be
able to move like they were saying there
should probably be in a vegetative state
um but I don't think they'd ever met a
Hibbert before
um
we don't like being told what to do and
um so yes or no like she you know she
can see she can hear
she speaks all the time which is great
um she'll probably need care for the
rest of her life
um
but I say you take it you know it's
um because there's 22 families who'd
take that tomorrow
and how are you doing now
there's a lot of guilt
um
like survival survivor's guilt because
I feel like if I was standing a meter to
the left or to the right like I wouldn't
be here right now
[Music]
I don't know how do you go through
something like that without uh
I don't waste a day and yeah I'm just
I'm just dead happy to be here because
you know I shouldn't be you know what I
mean so I just think it's a crime for me
not to
to live life to the full
after everything you've been through do
you see yourself as a hero no
the heroes are the ones that come back
in the box
they're the heroes
they've gave it all up
I've still got a fight
[Music]
we could see the police put up the tent
around his body and all the road taped
off is this man dead he can't be dead
only hit him a few times with the
baseball bat in the head and around the
shoulder and neck I went upload your
[ __ ] head off I went out about that
yes Jacob you're a punished man knocked
him out one punch I've just killed
someone